>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THIS IS THE TENTH DAY IN A ROW
THAT WE HAVE DEVOTED A LARGE
PORTION OF THE SHOW TO BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION.
WE HAVE DONE THAT BECAUSE THE
STORY MATTERS.
NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE THE SUPREME
COURT ITSELF MATTERS.
THE WAY KAVANAUGH HAS BEEN
TREATED BY THE DEMOCRATS IN
THE SENATE AS WELL AS BY THE
MEDIA AND THE LEFT WING
INTEREST GROUPS WHO DO THEIR
BIDDING IN CONCERT GETS THE
MOST BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY WE WANT
TO LIVE IN.
DOES EVERY AMERICAN DESERVE
DUE PROCESS?
ARE THE ACCUSED PRESUMED
INNOCENT RATHER THAN GUILTY?
DOES FAIRNESS STILL MATTER IN
THIS COUNTRY?
WELL, TO ALL OF THOSE WE
ANSWER YES.
THE LEFT ARGUES NO.
TO THEM ACQUIRING POWER
JUSTIFYING ANYTHING.
THAT IS THE REAL DEBATE HERE.
WE THOUGHT YOU SHOULD KNOW
THAT.
AFTER THE DEVELOPMENTS AND
THERE ARE MANY.
AFTER YESTERDAY'S HEARING, THE
DEBATE MUST BE DRAWN TO A
CLOSE.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE WATCHING
WHAT KAVANAUGH SAID TO THE
SENATE YESTERDAY WITHOUT FEEL
PROGRESS FOUND SYMPATHY.
THIS IS A DEEPLY SINCERE MAN
WHO BELIEVES HIS FAMILY HAS
BEEN DESTROYED BY FALSE AND
UNSUPPORTED ALLEGATIONS.
MANY WEPT AS THEY WATCH HIM
SPEAK.
DEMOCRATS REMAINED UNMOVED.
SOME ARGUE THAT KAVANAUGH'S
ANGUISH WAS ITSELF EVIDENCE
THAT HE IS A MONSTER.
AS IF ONLY A SEX CRIMINAL
WOULD RECOIL AT BEING CALLED A
SEX CRIMINAL.
>> A CALENDAR AND A DIARY.
VERY ORGANIZED GUY TO PUT IT
MILDLY.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT WAS
THE WRONG SOUND BITE BUT YOU
GET THE POINT.
BARBARA BOXER EXPLAINED TODAY
HIS ANGER ON STAGE MADE HER
THINK HE WAS CAPABLE OF
VIOLENCE.
WOULD YOU BE ANGRY IF THEY
SAID IT ABOUT YOU?
NO MATTER WHAT THEY SAY, THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T MEAN ANY OF
THIS PERSONALLY.
THEY DON'T HATE KAVANAUGH OR
HIS FAMILY.
THEY DON'T SEEK TO DESTROY
EITHER ONE.
THEY ARE JUST IRRELEVANT.
DEMOCRATS JUST WANT TO BE IN
CONTROL.
SO YESTERDAY THEY IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN STALLING FOR TIME AND
THEY DID THAT DEMANDING A
SEVENTH F.B.I. INVESTIGATION
INTO KAVANAUGH'S LIFE.
THE POINT IS RUN OUT THE CLOCK
ON HIS NOMINATION.
THEY CONTINUED THE TACTIC
TODAY AT TWO HEARINGS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE AFTERNOON
WHEN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RECONVENED.
WATCH THIS.
>> I CANNOT SIT HERE.
I CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN WHAT I
KNOW HISTORY WILL LOOK BACK AS
A DARK MOMENT AGAIN IN THE WAY
WE LOOK AT THE ANITA HILL AND
CLARENCE THOMAS HEARING.
I CAN'T PARTICIPATE AGAIN
RELEGATE OURSELVES TO WHAT I
BELIEVE IS A DARK, DARK
ELEMENT OF THE SOCIETY.
TO THAT, SIR, I WILL LEAVE.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS NEW
JERSEY SENATOR CORY BOOKER, A
MAN SO OILY HE QUALIFIES AS AN
ALTERNATIVE FUEL.
ALMOST NOBODY WHO KNOWS BOOKER
TAKES HIM SERIOUSLY.
BUT TODAY HE FOUND AN ALLY,
SURPRISINGLY AMONG
REPUBLICANS.
THAT WAS JEFF FLAKE OF
ARIZONA.
FLAKE DECLARED HE WOULD BE
VOTING FOR KAVANAUGH'S
NOMINATION.
THEN HE WAS CONFRONTED BY A
MOB OF PROTESTERS, THE YOUTH
WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WATCH.
>> YOU ARE ALLOWING SOMEONE
WHO IS UNWILLING TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HIS OWN
ACTIONS.
TO SIT IN THE HIGHEST COURT OF
THE COUNTRY.
AND TO HAVE THE ROLE OF
REPAIRING THE HARM THAT HAS
BEEN DONE IN THIS COUNTRY TO
MANY PEOPLE.
NO THANK YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU HAVE THE POWER.
>> MA'AM, DO YOU WANT --
>> I WANT TO TALK TO HIM.
DON'T TALK TO ME.
I UNDERSTAND.
BUT TELL ME I'M STANDING RIGHT
HERE IN FRONT OF YOU.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE -- DO YOU
THINK HE IS TELLING THE TRUTH?
>> Tucker: WOW!
THAT MAN LOOKS AFRAID AND
ASHAMED.
YOU DON'T OFTEN SEE SENATORS
LOOK LIKE THAT.
THIS KIND OF THING HAS BEEN
HAPPENING A LOT IN WASHINGTON.
I HAPPENED TO TED CRUZ WHEN HE
FOUND HIMSELF SURROUNDED BY
PEOPLE AT DINNER AND LEFT THE
RESTAURANT.
JEFF FLAKE CRUMBLED AND
ANNOUNCED HE WOULD NOT APPROVE
THE NOMINATION WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION.
DEMOCRATS CHEERED HIS CHANGE
OF HEART.
I APPLAUD SENATOR JEFF FLAKE'S
DECISION TO RISE ABOVE THE
PARTISAN CIRCUS ON DISPLAY IN
THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
JOE MANCHIN.
BUT IN WASHINGTON WHEN THEY
CONGRATULATE YOU ON LEAVING
THE PARTISAN CIRCUS, CHANCES
ARE YOU ARE NOW THE RING
MASTER OF THE FOR -- MASTER OF
THE CIRCUS.
JEFF FLAKE IS THAT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
IT DOESN'T MEAN A LOT.
THE F.B.I. DOES NOT WANT THE
CASE.
THERE IS NOTHING TO
INVESTIGATE HERE AND THEY SAID
THAT DEFINITIVELY ALREADY.
WEEKS AGO DIANNE FEINSTEIN
SENT THEM CHRSTINE BLASEY
FORD'S ORIGINAL LETTER AND
THAT WAS THEIR RESPONSE.
THIS IS NOT A FEDERAL CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
IT CANNOT BE.
NO FEDERAL CRIME HAS BEEN
ALLEGED.
ONLY POLICE THE MARYLAND CAN
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THIS.
THEY ARE NOT BECAUSE STRANGELY
CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD NEVER
FILED CHARGES AGAINST BRETT
KAVANAUGH IN THE JURISDICTION
WHERE SHE SAID IT TOOK PLACE.
INSTEAD THE F.B.I. WILL
CONDUCT WHAT IS CALLED A
SUPPLEMENTAL INVESTIGATION.
AGENTS WILL INTERVIEW ONLY
THOSE DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO
CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD'S
ORIGINAL ALLEGATION.
IN THIS CASE, THAT WOULD
AMOUNT TO CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD
AND BRETT KAVANAUGH, OF
COURSE, ALONG WITH THE THREE
PEOPLE FORD SAYS WERE PRESENT
WHEN SHE WAS ATTACKED IN 182.
THAT WOULD BE JUDGE, P.J.
SMITH AND LEYLAND KAISER.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT ALL FIVE
OF THE PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
GIVEN SWORN TESTIMONY.
YOU ARE AWARE OF WHAT THEY
HAVE SAID.
FOUR CATEGORICALLY DENIED
UNDER OATH FORD'S VERSION OF
THE STORY.
IF THEY DEVIATE FROM THE
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY, THEY COULD
FACE CRIMINAL PENALTIES.
SO WHAT CAN WE POSSIBLY LEARN
FROM HAVING THE F.B.I.
INTERVIEW THEM?
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE F.B.I.
MAKES NO JUDGMENTS IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
IT'S NOT ASSESSING CREDIBILITY
OR RENDER ANY CONCLUSION.
IT JUST DOES INTERVIEWS AND
SUMMARIZES THEM FOR LAWMAKERS.
THE F.B.I. NO MATTER WHAT THEY
TELL YOU IS NOT A TIE-BREAKER
IN THIS OR ANY OTHER
INVESTIGATION.
IT'S AN INVESTIGATIVE AGENCY
THAT WILL PROVIDE THE SENATE
WITH INFORMATION THAT SENATORS
ALREADY HAVE.
SO BRETT KAVANAUGH IS GOING TO
GET INTERVIEWED AGAIN.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE TO GET A
PROSTATE EXAM TO BE MORE
THOROUGHLY VETTED THAN
KAVANAUGH HAS BEEN IN THE NEXT
20 YEARS.
THEY MAY TRY THAT, TOO.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR TRUTH
THIS IS A POINTLESS EXERCISE.
YOU WOULDN'T CONSIDER IT.
BUT THE TRUTH IS NOT WHAT
ANYONE IS LOOKING FOR HERE AS
YOU MAY HAVE FIGURED OUT.
DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING MORE
BASELESS ALLEGATIONS WILL
EMERGE IN THE DELAY, DURING
WHICH THE F.B.I. IS
INVESTIGATING THINGS THAT HAVE
LONG BEEN INVESTIGATED.
PERHAPS ANOTHER REPTILIAN PORN
LAWYER WILL COME FORWARD WITH
ANOTHER CLIENT WITH FANTASIES
OF GANG RAPE OR MAYBE RITUAL
SATANIC ABUSE.
WHO KNOWS WHAT IT WILL BE?
WHEN THE CHARGES EMERGE, THE
DEMOCRATS WILL DEMAND NEW
PUBLIC HEARINGS ON EVERY ONE
OF THEM.
DEMOCRACY HANGS IN THE
BALANCE, THEY WILL TELL US.
MEANING THE ACCESS TO POWER
HANGS IN THE BALANCE.
IT'S NOT A COMPLICATED
FORMULA.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON KNOWS
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
EXCEPT FOR MAYBE A POOR JEFF
FLAKE.
PEOPLE WHO KNOW FLAKE SAY HE
MAY BELIEVE DEMOCRATS ARE
ACTING IN GOOD FAITH.
MAYBE HE IS AUDITIONING FOR A
NEW EMPLOYER.
HE IS LEAVING THE SENATE EARLY
NEXT YEAR.
EITHER WAY YOU HAVE TO BE AN
IDIOT TO THINK CAVING TO THIS
DEMAND WILL INDUCE THE
DEMOCRATS TO CALL OFF THE
SMEAR CAMPAIGN AGAINST BRETT
KAVANAUGH AND HIS FAMILY.
THEY WON'T.
THEY WILL ACCELERATE.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
IT'S WORKING.
BUT THERE IS A COST.
ESPECIALLY FOR REPUBLICANS.
AT THIS POINT KAVANAUGH ISN'T
JUST A SUPREME COURT NOMINEE.
HE IS A FOLK HERO TO MANY
PEOPLE.
INSPIRATION TO MILLIONS.
PEOPLE WHO SPENT THE LAST TWO
YEARS BEING BROWBEATEN AND
BULLIED BY THE MORAL
INFOREYOURS WERE BUOYED --
INFERIORS WERE BUOYED BY WHAT
HE SAID YESTERDAY.
THEY ARE UNFAIRLY MALIGNED
BECAUSE THEY IN THE WAY OF
OTHER PEOPLE GAINING POWER AND
HAVE BEEN COMMANDED TO SHUT UP
AND OBEY.
KAVANAUGH STOOD UP FOR THE
PEOPLE YESTERDAY AND HE RAISED
A MIDDLE FINGER TO THE
TORMENTERS AND THEY LOVE HIM
FOR IT.
KAVANAUGH IS FAR MORE POPULAR
WITH THE REPUBLICAN VOTERS
TONIGHT THAN ANY SINGLE
REPUBLICAN SENATOR.
HI IS MORE POPULAR THAN THE
SENATE AS A WHOLE.
KAVANAUGH WOULDN'T DESCRIBE IT